ça nous touche tous un par un
et qu'est ce que ça peut changer
enfants
on va tous quelques temps
mozart
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'autres bonjour je m'appelle mise en
jeu 80 damanaki
super bateau super malin
une mozart
tout ça pour un petit prout je vais
vraiment le mascara pour le coup tout ça
pour un petit prout
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais la première mais
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est
nous moi
ces cas
entre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
foot franchement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît à venir beaucoup
[Musique]
super c'est la mamie généré que ce soit
parce qu on était comme des fous vous
l'avez suivi comme à prendre ou à
laisser de ce soir
julia qui repart avec 106 volée la
croatie est la boîte j'ai terminé de
manger le mot qui va déboucher si tu
marches voir lalalala l'oseille lala
dans les prochains jours mais cyril se
pose depuis tout à l'heure ils avaient
sur plateau y regarde de plus à l'heure
et whitney sur les 100 mm sur l'eau